hello everybody my name is markli and
welcome back to let's play the study of
insanity them finished left for dead to
great that's fantastic anyway so I've
been around everywhere I've been
everywhere looking for this some [__]
Lantern and you guys managed to tell me
where it is it's under this pile of
rubble I'm pretty sure so I I didn't
even bother to realize that this was a
cabinet under here I didn't I didn't
even see it and I actually have been
down to The Cellar and I found this
chipper down there but the problem is
these don't combine so I don't know what
the deal is with that but I'm going to
get the lantern so I'm hoping that
something will help me no you don't get
Oh serious that better there oh you son
of a [__] you son of a [__] you little
bastard you little bastard I'm going to
I'm going to turn you on I'm burn you
I'm going to burn you okay so anyway
I've got a stone chipper now I'm not
exactly sure what to do with it I've
kind of been wandering around trying it
in different places but I'm thinking
that now that I have this land
turn I can actually make some progress
in this some [__] so I'm going to go
this way and then I'm going to hop on
this table and then I'm going to do a
sweet 360 yeah nailed it yeah then I'm
going to go in here and there's actually
a painting here that I noticed too this
painting is like this painting feels
loose but it won't bdge so there must be
a mechanism nearby and I originally
thought that may be one of the
candlesticks but none of the
candlesticks seem to be movable they're
all just you know normal candlesticks so
I'm I I don't know where that mechanism
in I'm going to go back in the seller
because it was dark as balls steam
finish Skyrim good job steam you're
really on the ball I'm so glad that
you're here to assist me in all my
downloading
needs all right so anyway I'm a little
aggravated because I ran around for like
more than an episode just wasted time on
me going oh don't know where am I what
am I
doing and then just you know you guys
know how much I hate being stuck what
that something happen I don't know
anyway I've been in what the oh yeah
that was locked he wait a minute hey
back
huh no okay all right that's not that's
no all right um in here maybe I found
like every single item in every nook and
cranny like I looked everywhere for this
Lantern except the obvious place cuz I'm
an
edet I'm an
edet I'm an edet anyway there's a room
in here this is where I found a chipper
in one of these and I don't think
there's anything else but then again I
couldn't really see cuz it was dark as
balls as I quoted anything in you no
anything in you you
e no I just I I I don't know what the
deal is with not being able to combine
the stone chipper and whatnot but it
seems
it it
seems that everything on my inside wants
to be on my outside I even try to
hear like I don't know what the dealio
is like what's the dealio to use Ancient
lingo like I can't even combine them I
don't know I don't know what going on I
it just it seems like it should work
doesn't it it do don't it you know it it
really do and it just don't you think it
be like it is but it don't I know that's
not the right quote don't judge
me I don't know I don't know I don't
think I missed anything down here there
quite literally nothing to
[Music]
do all right I also tried it on doors
upstairs too so if I don't find
something soon I'm going to pull all my
hair out and then jump around the room
naked would you like to see that would
you like to see me jumping around naked
all right you probably would you sick
freaks all right I'm going to start
moving stuff too who knows could be
under something just like the lantern
was just like a freaking Lantern was
like a freaking could be under this
could be over here could
be oh sorry
sorry all right anyway checking in here
everything seems
normal nothing seems to be telling me to
progress I've tried these things on
every door it's just don't work just
don't freaking give me that don't work
nothing works doesn't work and I don't
know why gers Dar it I mean gers Dar it
there was nothing under here there's
nothing in the darkness there's nothing
up here I don't have any more
keys I I have a hammer and chipper but
don't know what to do with
them no a key must be nearby you lying
sack of [__] you lying piece of junk you
lying sack of octopus
excrement I'm about to run out of oil
too are any of these like secret maybe
switches no
no no uh-uh that's a negative no wrong
oh no again let's see I lit some of
these actually I checked in here
I checked behind all of these things cuz
I thought there might be something but
apparently there's not Dr my Lantern
just cuz I I can see it in the dark a
bit better you know if I just let it go
but no uh oh skulls it's so
scary wait a minute oh look secret
oil oh well that come on come on I hear
wind but no that was just that was a
trick the only one is behind here I know
I know I I know and like a mous and then
I was in here cuz I lit that I think I
did I don't know there just doesn't seem
to be anything I'm at a
loss and ooh more oil secret oil oh God
I found every single secret item every
one I bet every single one and what does
it get me gets me a an aneurysm and an
understand people my audience see I'm
insane am I I'm not insane all
right what is that why is that glowing
was it glowing is it glowing no it's not
glowing I open the
door good for
Mir I open the door okay anyway I'm
going to go I'm going to keep trying I'm
not going to give up giving up's not in
my nature maybe if I play the piano
it'll ding ding D dong ding click click
painting opened up huh weird but no at
last it is not to be no burn the chair
burn you [__] oh no you can't escape
Your Fate Stay in there just stay in
there and you're going to watch him
you're just going to watch him
burn I've gone crazy oh look another
secret item and maybe there's hope that
I have missed
others you can't save them you're just
an inanimate object nope nothing behind
there painting no go let's see her hair
clock
book no nothing in there nothing up
there nothing behind there you don't
make me I will burn you all I will
destroy you wait what's that
papers I see you in there don't think
you can hide from me no one can hide
from me I am nothing behind that
painting B
bammo no not going to happen nothing
behind there rabbit don't make me burn
you
two okay so I'm cheed here now I'm going
to go sequentially in each of these
rooms here this is where I oh it's back
all the stuff is still clogged again I
try a shirt that should definitely help
me look fashionable for the
ball what ball do you ask of you
know
the okay I don't think there's anything
else in here I'm pretty sure sure this
room has been fished out wooho wait no
wait I see you I see you oil another
secret item I I am good at finding the
secret items but just not finding the
like there can't be that big of a
difference between the stuff that's
hidden and this the items I mean when
the guy made this he had to think oh I'm
going to hide So Many Items they're
never going to find them all but I'm
finding them all and not the plot ones
like
why why I read all your notes I I did I
can't Hammer chip your thingy
open if you know what I mean I can't I
can't
MH I just don't know the pain into balls
is this entertaining me being
aggravated me going Arctic
crazy I don't know maybe maybe
is what say
what take yeah what the how can I stick
you
what maybe I have gone crazy oh wait I
got to try this again hang on I found a
new
game who needs to progress in the story
when we've got sticky walls no get up
there get there we go come on get up
there yeah no you're too fat to stay up
there you're fat you can't stay on the
walls They're laughing at you H okay
anyway smash anything no how about you
smash no nothing that's a
surprise oh see and this is a a special
tool might be
required is this like a bug I can't
combine the the camera and chipper so
there
go like it's not going to let me
progress is that is that the deal is
that the deal is that the deal yo
a stone chipper that combination does
not work this door is obviously locked
forever okay I've checked every single
oh the last item I bet that is the last
item oh since someone else got a kick
out of this last time I
[Laughter]
[Music]
read it's
so laugh laugh with
me
got God D it I've been through here so
many
times what am I
missing what tell me your
secret there's got to be something that
I'm missing some clue that I just I
can't see see near little masturbation
of the mind but nothing I checked all
the paintings besides that
one maybe there's a secret
wine connection thing lever do that
what's this puddle of ooze get out of
there I said get out of there maybe
something else secret hidden in the
closet secret bottle lever no
girl let me up here excuse
me NP
mm I've burned through all my secret oil
trying to find the secret ending exit
thing and to no avail I am lost and
forsaken in the
wind I need to think I need to think got
to unleash it
a oh the secrets of the enigmas that are
the existentialism of Amnesia to
remember what we have forgotten is to
understand who we really
are oh it's just unreal the
interpretations of the
existentialism that is the understanding
of
God but then we are all just an
imagining of the IM imination of a
child I feel stupider I feel much I feel
much stupider now I'm not exactly sure
what happened there I'm not I'm not
sure so anyway I seem to be lost in
running in circles I turned to the
occult I turned to Insanity I turn to
the
stupid nothing
nothing or everyone has forsaken me I am
lost and alone with no answers and so
many
questions so many I don't know why I
just lit that that's another question to
add on to the pile that is the burden of
my mind no I'm not I'm not hit Mar yet
yet anymore I'm not hit Mar okay I'm
just going to huddle up by this candle
and wait for my inevitable inevitable
Doom all right anyway so if you can help
me out again cuz I seem to be
stck I've now wasted two episodes full
but I'm not going to this one's going
online unless it's not then how are you
seeing
this okay anyway thank you so much for
watching sorry I didn't make any
progress and if the answer is so obvious
that I'm incredibly stupid please tell
me so like I don't mind you can you can
let it all out I don't mind so I click
The annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I'll see you you in
the next video
bye-bye